it's one of the reasons why they like to
use golf as a man yes exactly that's a
great there's two things one you get to
see how someone handles competition you
don't get to see if they cheat you know
because people do cheat in golf you know
it's an interesting story a good friend
of mine his his dad was playing golf
with this man and his wife was there as
well and the wife saw the dad moved the
or saw this man that he's playing golf
with moved the ball and she said do not
go into business with this man do not
trust this man he's a cheater he cheated
at golf
hmm and he thought it was not that big a
deal it's like it's just a game of golf
no this is a big deal hmm turns out the
guy was a [ __ ] criminal just took a
while to find out mm-hmm I mean he wound
up doing a lot of other things that how
you do some things is oftentimes how you
do everything
yeah well that's why people are so
interested in games yes you know because
a person really is well games this is
again why I'm such an admirer of Piaget
because he knew very well that game is a
microcosm of reality yeah that's why we
like meaning you have to have an
explanation for why people like games
yeah you know I've been talking about
this a lot my lectures too is you think
well you know any game like he's any
competitive game soccer is a good
example it's basically a hunting game
hey because you're you're firing a
projectile at a target okay so the
targets the goal and the projectiles the
ball but it doesn't matter is that so
you have it
you have teams that are figuring out how
to hunt properly then you think well to
hunt properly you have to put the ball
in the net as many times as you possibly
can so and so you organize yourself in a
hierarchy to facilitate that but then
that's that's not the whole story
because you tell your kids it doesn't
matter whether you win or lose it
matters how you play the game and the
kids all freaked out about that because
he doesn't know what you mean and he
says well what do you mean dad I'm
trying it's supposed to try to win and
you say I don't know what I mean but
it's it's still true but here's what you
mean is that if you're in a league
you're not trying to win the soccer game
you're trying to win the soccer
championship and to win the championship
you have to win a whole bunch of games
and the rules to win a whole bunch of
games aren't the same as the rules to
win one game you know like
you could go flat out as the prima donna
and bend and bend the rules and cut
corners and exhaust everyone and win the
game and then lose the next three
because that's a stupid medium to long
term strategy or you could be like the
superstar and hog the ball all the time
and never give your teammates a chance
to develop but then you're injured and
your team is out so those that's a
stupid strategy too so do you think well
what you have to do to win the
championship is that you have to
organize your team so that the best
players lead but that everybody gets
developed and that you play the medium
to long term game in a fair way in a
fair and decent way okay so you think
well that's how you win a championship I
talked to a coach a while back and he
said one of the things he did to select
athletes was to watch what happened when
they scored a goal and if they were
celebrating on their own you know in
sort of an egotistical way then that
wasn't such a good sign but if they
scored a goal or a touchdown or whatever
it was and their whole entire team came
in and bobbed them and then like lifted
them up on their shoulders and they
thought that guy is an athlete because
not only can he put the goal put the
ball in the net but he does it in a way
that benefits the entire team and that's
the person you want around for the long
run and so then the goal isn't just to
put the ball on the goal the goal is to
put the ball in the goal the largest
number of times while simultaneously
benefiting as many as your of your
fellow players as you can't well
although I think that's a great strategy
I don't think that's necessarily the
meaning of it doesn't matter if you win
or lose it's how you play the game I
think what I don't think people think of
it in terms of like a long-term strategy
for championship leagues well when
they're saying it doesn't matter whether
you win or lose it's how you play the
game meaning don't cheat yeah do your
best
yeah and learn right but I think that's
right well learn how to handle failure
right learn how to handle victory we'll
also learn from the experience itself
like if you make a mistake and you
you're trying your hardest but you make
an error because someone has a counter
to that yeah then you learn from that
yeah that's how you play the game right
and you don't think and you win just
because you got lucky that's not as good
as playing intelligently and expanding
your schist and losing yes because the
other people are superior and then you
learn from the fact that they figured
out a way to have solutions to all the
problems that you present yes okay so so
one of the things that you're pointing
out is that while you're playing you
want to be expanding your range of
skills so that you get better at playing
the next game but then you think well
even the soccer championship isn't the
whole game
right because your life is a whole
series of games of chance of different
ideas the championships will come if you
continue to excel and get excellent yes
and also if people invite you to play
yes so there's both those are the two
things so that's the goal right the goal
isn't to put the ball in the net the
goal is to get excellent and to be
invited to play and the mechanism is
that you put the ball in the goal and
that makes sense see that helps explain
why people find competitive sports so
unbelievably compelling because you can
be cynical about it you can say well
look there's fifty thousand people there
watching you know somebody kick a
spheroid object into a net who the hell
cares like and but but that's not the
issue what you're what you are in fact
doing is you're going there to watch
people develop expertise and to learn to
play reciprocally in a noble and ethical
manner and all of that sport when it's
done properly is a direct physical
incarnation of that ethic